لقد ذكرت الآن استخدام كل
الموارد المتاحة لعمليات الإخلاء ، فلماذا
لم تأمر الجيش
بتوسيع المحيط الأمني حول مط
ر كابول ، هل لديك أي خطط لل
يام بذلك ، فمن المحتمل أن يتطلب ذلك ال
زيد من القوات الأمريكية وهل تفكر في عم
يات الإنقاذ  استعادة الأمريكيين
والحلفاء الأفغان العالقين خلف
نقاط
تفتيش طالبان ، الإجابة الأخيرة هي نعم على
السؤال الأخير الذي نفكر فيه في كل عملية
وكل فرصة وكل وسيلة
يمكننا من خلالها نقل
الأشخاص إلى المطار وهذا هو رقم واحد
السبب الثاني سبب عدم ذهابنا.  خرجنا
وبدأنا وأقمنا
طريقًا خارجيًا خارج المطار في كابول هو
أنه من المحتمل أن يرسم الكثير من
العواقب غير المقصودة فيما يتعلق
بأشخاص ليسوا في الواقع
جزءًا من طالبان ، لقد كنا
على اتصال دائم مع قيادة طالبان
على الأرض
في كابول
بالإضافة إلى قيادة طالبان في
تاهو وكنا ننسق
ما نفعله ولهذا السبب تمكنا من
السابق
كيف تمكنا من إخراج جميع موظفي سفارتنا
من كيفية إخراج الجميع من
السفارة بأمان ، وكانت هذه هي المسافة
التي ساعدنا بها في إخراج الفرنسيين
من سفارتهم وخروجهم من سفارتهم ، لذلك
يبقى السؤال أنه ستكون هناك
أحكام على الأرض من قبل
القادة العسكريون في الوقت الحالي
ولا يمكنني التكهن بإصدار كل من
هذه الأحكام